so the first i was made aware of rapid
unsaid gender dysphoria which is what
you write about in in your book
uh was a study from brown it was a
preliminary study that was put out
talking about this phenomenon that
you're talking about groups of young
girls who were sort of
one they were all experiencing
discomfort in various ways and
for various different reasons and one
girl would then suggest well i'm
actually transgender and then many of
the girls would suddenly
decide that they were transgender as
well and this was put out by a scholar
at brown university
and brown immediately walked back to
study and then apologized for ever
having put out the study in the first
place
uh you know what's been your experience
with censorship
now that you've actually talked openly
about this phenomenon from the moment i
i got a publisher there was a campaign
to have my book
dropped by my publisher to have my
publisher drop me
as a client and then um as an author
then
of course when my book was coming out um
amazon
you know refused to um sponsor ads for
the book so
amazon refused to allow my publisher
rather to sponsor ads
then you know journalists all kinds of
top journalists wanted to review the
book because it's an interesting topic
there is you know you talk to most
parents and you ask them if they have
middle school students
they know that all of a sudden all their
kids you know friends a huge number of
them are trans
and they want to know why and it's an
interesting topic so a lot of people
wanted to review it
and all the major newspapers and
magazines told them absolutely not we
are not touching this book
um and and and then um joe rogan had me
on
which was wonderful and and um spotify
employees threw a fit and they demanded
that the
the episode be stripped from his
platform and he's
you know stood up to them and so has
spotify which has
really been a huge victory against
cancel culture but you see what they had
to go through
and then most recently target.com
stripped my book from
from you know being available uh for
purchase
i mean it is it is pretty incredible i
mean we've seen people like
chase strangio who is a trans justice
advisor
over at the aclu calling for your book
to be banned because the american civil
liberties union
uh is no longer no longer the american
civil liberties union it is actually
just a left-wing interest group that is
fully fine apparently with shutting down
civil liberties up to and including
censorship
of particular tracts they don't like so
what is
the the reason that a lot of these
people say that they are trying to ban
your book or censor your book
is because of the suggestion that it
that it somehow threatens the safety
of trans people and we get this in a
wide variety of settings we saw this
with
senator tom cotton writing an op-ed
about the use of the insurrection act to
put down rioting and looting in major
cities and the new york times staffers
saying that this threatened their safety
somehow
and the new york times op-ed editor
james bennett being canned on that basis
this constant call that things i don't
like threaten me uh has been carried
pretty far particularly with regard to
trans issues the idea being that if you
don't use someone's preferred pronoun
you should be barred from social media
because you might be dead naming them
and this threatens their safety
what do you make of the arguments that
you know books that
that question the reality of the
diagnosis of gender dysphoria not
overall but in particular cases threaten
people's safety
i think that the the reason that this
this issue engenders such
extremist response is because they know
that if the word gets out what teenagers
are doing
that people that most americans will be
so horrified
that it will be shut down i mean right
now
a teenager can walk into a clinic at 15
and without her parents permission after
being goaded by her therapist her
teachers
and and social media influencers she
will go into it she can go into a clinic
on her own
walk out that day with a course of
testosterone a schedule
three control substance and forever
alter her body
and she doesn't even need a therapist
note and and so i think the hysteria is
really because
this isn't a right or left issue to the
extent that the most the parents who
call me are politically
progressive but but universally
americans are horrified as soon as they
learn about what's going on
it seems like there's obviously an
attempt not just to shut down you but
also even parents
who are asking questions about their own
kids activities parents are being shamed
by social media
their own kids are saying that you're a
bad parent if you refuse to allow me to
go get a testosterone treatment
or parents who say that we ought to
engage in watchful waiting are labeled
transphobes if you have a two-year-old
and your two-year-old goes to school i
first see a future here
where there are going to be child
protective services calls being made
if your kid goes to school says they're
a member of the opposite gender and
then you say at home no you're not and
the kid goes to school and tells a
teacher i think child protective
services shows up sometime in the next
five years given the way the trends are
moving
that's already happening and in fact
this is probably the most egregious
example of gaslighting
today is what's happening to these
parents so
so they will have their it's not this is
such a horror
to parents because they're being lied to
and backstabbed by
everyone so the teachers will lie to
their faces about what's going on at
school they'll re you know let the child
rename himself and call you know
let him use the opposite sex bathrooms
never telling the teacher that they've
officially changed
him or her with regard you know within
the school the therapists lie to the
parents
the the social workers interfere the the
um
you know doctors will supply medicine
without the parents permission i mean
you know these parents are are are so
attacked and and as you said you know
their friends consider them transphobes
and whatever
i mean the the you know sanctity and
autonomy
and integrity of the family is so under
assault
um on this issue and i have had calls
from parents who say
i'm terrified of losing custody but
listen i know
my kid i only spent oh i don't know a
hundred thousand
hours raising her i know her i'm a
political progressive but this doesn't
seem right it came out of nowhere
and and i'm supposed to trust the
judgment of a therapist
who spent one 45-minute session with her
and claims to know her better than i do
um you know it's it's very it's really
horrifying what's going on
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show sunday special if you
did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all our future
content